peu
[Musique]
l'ipad
à
c'est
allez
[Applaudissements]
merci
au fur et à mesure des spectacles des
répliques et puis aussi de la d'aidés
publiques parce que c'est aussi le
public qui fait le spectacle
on arrive comme ça crée un personnage et
ypres en mixant me pro a mais il faut
trouver le bon dosage entre la
caricature et le naturel la mariage
comme une caricature donc il fallait
aussi composer un personnage qui soit
visuellement aussi fort que la maria
mais pas tomber non plus dans une
caricature grossière - du public
ben dis quand même je peux y aller comme
ça où le rebond des deux conneries oui
alors on y va on ne fout pas mordre en
fout pas je suis là je te présente le
fils ou bon je me suis inspiré de des
histoires de la terre et puis des gens
que j'ai rencontrés ici en campagne pour
pour créer le spectacle et l'amusant ça
fait oublier grand mère c'est ça ça vous
rappelle les grands mères d'ici en bas
oui sa grand mère à lui
marcel m'a connu tout petit et c'est le
les heures que j'ai passés chez ma
grand-mère et ça aussi c'est un petit
peu du pour presque du blue square en
fin de compte les blues de l'enfance le
le fait jouer maria bodin
rama
excellent
vous avez les papilles et expekt
ce sont là
euros donc dans des décors naturels il
encore plus leur place que sur scène les
bodin's ckoi ruraux euros ouais c'est le
pluriel de rural on sait pas vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]